Jimmy how you doing what he brought to
today I'm doing all right i just
finished the review on this one guys can
sweet see it yeah that's what we're
talking about yeah xbox one s I don't
know which camera should probably one of
those two that's good yes I just
reviewed this this morning rather the
NDA just left this morning yeah let's uh
skin to that we are gonna be talking
about the xbox one s which what is it
like publicly did available today okay
cool so I could get one if I wanted to
but there's one right here so I'm going
to take this afterward but anyway people
are like curious about this because a
like you know like the Scorpio is also
announced and right now that's the
working title I don't know if that's I
just finally yeah product Scorpio the
xbox one launched with a few problems
and everything like hardware wise its
kind of always it was always up for a
discussion on a variety of fronts but I
guess people are curious about this I
guess the overarching question which we
can get into later after we talked about
the specs and what's new with it and
what it does for people who might have
an xbox the organ question being is it
worth getting with the Scorpio on the
horizon yeah just jump right in there I
guess what's your take yeah I mean it
really depends on where you're coming
from so I would say if you have an xbox
one already then don't upgrade to this
unless you really want the HDR and 4k
support so this xbox can do HD or 4k
video streaming so yeah I wouldn't
upgrade if you already have an xbox one
if you do you know want that you know
those media features and then this thing
is as far as I'm concerned a must-buy
it's actually cheaper than like
dedicated players out there yeah and it
comes with an xbox one yeah well that
was a thing like what it's guy like what
4k blu-ray the HDR which like HDR is
like high dynamic range but basically a
lot more contrast right yeah more
contrast it's a higher color gamut as
well yeah so yeah I remember you saying
like in the review that like the black
pixels almost look like they're not even
lit up at all right there's like you
know like ideally um but and that's like
supposedly the next big thing apart from
4k like four times resolution or
whatever really yeah I think it's
actually in my opinion it's probably a
bigger difference you know HDR is a
bigger difference than a 1080p 24 k
upgrade mm-hmm the colors are just
really
much more vibrant yeah so can you tell
us about like obviously it's forty
percent smaller I've heard it's pretty
heavy fritz apparently it isn't exactly
forty percent smaller I don't know what
the exact percentage is but if you
consider like the fact that it has an
integrated power brick it's actually
it's actually like really impressively
small because the power brick on the
original xbox was massive there's no
good place to put that thing ever like a
behind like an entertainment center just
bury it under dirty clothes yeah and
pray it catches fire yes your clothes
you don't want yes so the power brick is
like back here I believe it's a lot
smaller this time around okay it's a
little bit more power efficient and it's
like can tell me about the specs I'm I'm
very I'm gonna leave this to YouTube's
i'm done with the specs are largely the
same still has a AMD a core processor i
think it's clocked out like 1.7
gigahertz the GPU is actually has been
it's it's a little faster this time
around it's i think it's up from like
153 megahertz to like 914 not a lot it's
a seven percent boost and while some
games can benefit slightly from this
it's gonna be pretty hard to notice it's
mostly for the performance boost is
mostly for HDR support okay can that
someone's asking the twitch can this
stand vertically just like any other
console can I don't have the standing
right now but it can without it it's
just it's sort of like the pay station
where it can stand vertically but um
good this way are you guys vertical
standards or horizontal I always want to
be a vertical standard huh you know like
I think about it like yeah I could be
that guy vertically me up right is the
aspirational poised pose for your xbox
and poise and poise yeah but I never
managed to like get the stands find a
way to arrange it it's just I think most
media centers are more geared towards
like a horizontal kind of set up anyhow
unless you're gonna put it on top of the
table just rotate 30 degrees oh there
you go yeah guys the TV's gonna be like
super high up on the side so there are
updates right out of the gate obviously
um I was reading it they take up 400
gigs is that correct or between the OS
and updates yes so this put this down
the board sure um at security live in
California
earthquakes yeah so this is the two
terabyte version I wanted to see you
know after the OS updates and the
firmware and all that stuff you know how
much space would I have you know to pay
wrong with and it was 1.6 terabytes so
that means they essentially 400 so but
that raises a question then if you buy
the 500 gigabyte version you're only
going to have one hundred gigabytes so I
asked Microsoft this actually and they
basically kind of gave me a non-answer
man screw that that's strange that's a
real serious question that people need
answer no I definitely answered them and
they deal I know I know yeah they didn't
I didn't answer is behind that's I can't
I can't verify that um because what's it
was like he was saying something with um
like there's something to do with like
the summer sale like taking up some I
don't know he was sanctioned to somewhat
summer sailing his answer so seasonally
your Xbox may have what was the what was
like the baseline xbox one storage when
it first came out 500 oh yeah yeah you
after everything else downloaded no no
after uh that's don't need the xbox one
that I remember yeah okay yeah um how
was just like your experience been like
performance wise playing games did you
like did you get a lot of time playing
games that at all yeah so I played about
a half dozen games or slow I mean it's
you know it is seven percent faster but
a lot of games are actually they
actually use like locked frame rates
like for instance if if you're playing a
game and it's like locked at 30 frames
per second well just because it gets you
know seven percent faster it's still
locked at 30 so you're not going to see
any difference okay so if a game doesn't
feature a locked frame rate then
theoretically you can so but like being
able to tell the difference is gonna be
really hard did you like in general kind
of I don't know did can certain games in
certain cases perform actually better on
this number reports came out june that
like there are certain specs with this
it was loud if there are games that
don't have unlocked frame rates then
theoretically yes okay get up to a seven
percent i was curious with this
releasing like whether this would tell
us anything about the Scorpio which is
still largely like some of its under
wraps I don't think we're this is
indicative of anything because it's such
a minor upgrade over the xbox one right
yeah
from the actual physical sense honestly
I feel like the performance difference
is you're going to see like it's not
really a selling point for the console
you shouldn't buy this because it's
going to be maybe seven percent I mean
so it's it's maybe seven percent faster
but like a video card you can overclock
that to be like fifteen percent faster
so like that's mean it's not a huge
thing just yeah spective I mean I wonder
how much this is just I mean obviously
she's filling the gap before the Scorpio
comes out because we're getting into
those you know but like the more of a pc
life cycle for a console it's not like
just gonna be an xbox one xbox to
anymore yeah and i want to be what you'd
see like s for every generation sort of
like the iphone oh yeah i'm wondering
like if it's this how much of this was a
reaction to like PS 4.5 or whatever to
fill that gap and kind of compete still
and especially the NX being and coming
out of the spring supposedly maybe just
microsoft was trying to fill that it's a
real easy way to renew interest in their
console a console that hasn't been
selling as well as the competition yeah
you know hey here's a new version it's
sleeker it's sexier it's no longer this
big hulking thing and yet maybe it's a
little bit faster and maybe you get some
more media stuff with it as well yeah
like that might tip some people over the
edge mm-hmm and make microsoft look like
they understand the problems with the
original xbox one in are improving it
yeah because there's like apart from the
actual hardware there's nothing else
like they're not like updating any it's
gonna be just if you turn it on its kind
of seemed like an Xbox one experience
right apart from minor yoga instances
that doesn't have a connect port though
so you'll need a like a USB adapter food
which is a bummer well I'm escape there
are big goals man that's true yeah there
are people though who I think maybe do
use the voice commands mm-hmm but you
don't have to trade in your xbox one if
you already do that you've already got
one yeah probably need to worry about it
do either of you like aside from the
fact that you're reviewing it for work
plan on getting one um I'm currently
borrowing an xbox one from work and the
idea of owning this sounds good to me
the idea of spending money on it does
not yeah because the Scorpio is looming
right so I don't know yeah I'm attracted
to it but I'm not jumping at it yeah i
mean i think my my desk space is like
it's pretty full right now and I to be
honest I mostly play a play on pc but i
do think it is
the the best and sexiest Xbox there is
and it's weird cuz I called it sexy in
the review in the comments are like how
can you call him inanimate think sexy it
was like I Lamborghini can be guys sexy
don't know how can you be a jerk on the
internet comment like that a plethora of
ways yes yeah so I guess I don't know is
there anything else you should know like
specs wise that you covered it like
whether I get the big question being
like if it's worth getting in the gap
which you were saying it's kind of been
a strange it's in a very strange space
because I don't think we've ever
encountered a new system refresh with
the company announcing a new next-gen
console before or at least I can't well
they all in a scenario they showed the
Refresh of the xbox 360 when they
announced the xbox one they came out
with an even slimmer version of the xbox
360 okay there are like three or four
versions of but I mean you gotta
remember the Scorpio is gonna be really
expensive yeah and they've even come out
and said like that's good and pricey so
you know I think about in those terms
right like if you want to be a part of
the xbox ecosystem and it's gonna be
backwards compatible exactly so yeah do
you think like Sony and Microsoft
released the xbox one and ps4 knowing
that the life cycle would become like
this sir that's just very much adapting
on the fly to what pc like are now I
mean when they shipped it to the
architecture that is no longer like semi
custom chips and they're sort of I guess
they are maybe a little semi cos i mean
their customized yeah but you know you
don't mean like the their x86 it's not
like they're making like yeah like weird
power pc chips anymore that's
interesting question I actually kind of
wrote an article that touches upon that
I think it I mean you'd have to ask them
but like going to an x86 architecture
which is the same architecture to the
computers use pcs use it opens the door
so maybe they kind of had that in mind I
don't know if like you know prix 2013
before these consoles were out and these
consoles were designed you know much
earlier than that i don't know if they
had you know concrete plans just yet but
i think it was just like if we wanted to
we probably could yeah so yeah i don't
know i personally am probably i'm gonna
hold off on this i have an xbox one I've
been you I use over you is so six I'd it
does look really good in it like just it
also just seems like it would fit better
in the space i have as opposed to that
vcr player of a council that i use now
and then again i bring this up all the
time because noise
that much but my roommate Jake Decker
has the loudest xbox one ever so I might
buy one for him so I have to deal with
that thing anymore we're like jerk
dicker jerk Decker his xbox is loud that
was one its fan is like playing maracas
when it spins around I don't know how
else to describe it without like
actually being like I don't know the
technical terms what happening some egg
rolls eyes a maraca technical terms I
have no idea but anyway yeah that is the
xbox one s you can read the full review
on gamespot right now Jimmy wrote it
overall maybe hold off you want to
Scorpio if you don't have an xbox one go
for this it's smaller it's kind of a
similar experience but yet let us know
you think I just know if you think
you're gonna get one let us know what
you think if you might hold off like I
will for the Scorpio in the comments
below thanks so much Jimmy